Tom motto is a former Chicago Bear
wide-receiver and current host of the
popular waddle and Silvie show on ESPN
1000 in Chicago as well as an analyst
for the mothership let me go back to
draft night Tom the reaction that fans
had and then the next day on your radio
show or the first time you were back on
what was the reaction of Mitchell true
Biscay being drafted what the hell was
Ryan base doing trading up to get a guy
that the San Francisco 49ers had no
interest in that was the initial
response from most Bears fans but you
know worse a quarterback starved City I
think when things kind of calm down
everyone was excited that maybe they
have found the guy that will lead us to
better times over the next decade all
right your show after the Broncos
performance by true Biscay what was the
reaction is he's going to Canton sooner
rather than later listen I could break
off a hot take for you as well and tell
you that you know he's destined for
greatness but I'm one that would rather
tap the brakes and acknowledge that yes
he handled everything much better than
maybe some of us thought he would
initially because he had such little
experience at the collegiate level he
showed he was an athlete he showed that
the stage wasn't too too big for him his
accuracy was there obviously the arm
strength you do acknowledge he was
playing against twos and threes but you
also have to also acknowledge he was
playing with twos and threes so he gave
us hope and and that's something we
haven't had in the Windy City for quite
some time there was an article in the
Chicago Tribune earlier this week that
talked about John Fox's future might be
attached to Mitchell true Biscay and you
put in Chaves key and then if you see
that he's actually progressing and the
team has a future and he is your
starting quarterback then you don't get
rid of John Fox as opposed to Mike
Glennon is your quarterback sure Biscay
doesn't play and you guys go you know
you have three wins or four wins
John Fox will likely be shown the door
yeah I think this who plays is going to
be dictated by the quarterbacks
themselves and not the front office or
not the coach I mean look John after a
three and thirteen season he understands
I mean this isn't his first rodeo he
needs to win some games too
to create a little job security in this
town I think we're going to find out
over the next couple of weeks whether or
not Mitch can take that next step I
think they have every intention of
starting Mike Glennon and then moving
Mitch along as fast as he shows them
that he's capable of moving but I have
all the confidence in the world that if
John Fox feels that Mitch Chu Biscay is
ready to go and gives the Bears the best
chance to win games that they're going
to play Mitch and and I don't think as
an organization it's going to be based
on what John feels his job security or
job status is as John would tell you he
has a few pelts on the wall and this
isn't the first time he's done this so I
think he has got nakiya's confidence in
himself and playing wide receiver you
know body language you can look at or
you can look at your quarterback and
you'd lose confidence in him you know
these wide receivers with Jacksonville
with Blake bortles I mean they're not
hiding their displeasure with him what
is that like as a court as a wide
receiver when you lose confidence in
your quarterback or you know he's lost
confidence in himself yeah it's
difficult like my quarterback was Jim
Harbaugh and I dare I say I always had
quarterback or had confidence in him I
did but I also wouldn't want to be on
the wrong side of Jim Harbaugh these
days if he heard the comment that I made
that I didn't have confidence in him I
think what ends up happening is is you
don't trust the system in the
quarterback the quarterbacks I think it
usually starts with the quarterback not
trusting the receiver and then you get a
little its second it off means disaster
in this at this level because of how
good these defensive players are and
when you walk into a huddle and you
don't believe in each other you've
already defeated so I can understand why
the guys in Jacksonville struggle with
one another now they had very little to
no success in it and it's not a good
situation and if you were their
receivers you know it's a group that
that was pointed in the right direction
and a couple of guys that put up some
huge numbers and when they see those
numbers dip and their performance goes
down everybody's looking to point a
finger
you see some of the shoddy play whether
it's some starters or even backups and
then Colin Kaepernick comes into play
here it almost feels like how desperate
is a team to bring him in because these
owners know he can be bad for business
but do you bring him in as a backup or
are you going to bring him in because
you're desperate enough you have to
bring him in as a starter if you see
there's a situation with the team that
is playoff ready a good team are you
more likely to bring in Kaepernick as
his starter or as a backup I think
you're more likely to bring him in as a
backup one man's opinion my opinion is
is just that Colin is not at this point
a starting quarterback in the NFL you
have to tailor your offense to his
strengths I think he does some nice
things but ultimately if defense has
been him and he's ultimately asked he
has to play the position from the pocket
and played efficiently and what we've
seen the last couple of years doesn't
inspire confidence in me that he can do
that so if if he's starting quarterback
in the league in my opinion no is he
capable of being a backup quarterback in
this league absolutely put on the tape
of Ryan Mallett from last night and
there are a lot of guys who have jobs in
the NFL as backup quarterbacks who
aren't as good as Colin Kaepernick and
don't have the resumes that Colin has I
think again if you're a backup
quarterback you can you can do some
things that can help your team with it
the offense doesn't have to be
completely reset I just think if you
bring in in Dan as a starter you have to
start tailoring what you're trying to do
to his skillset and I just don't know
that that's the most efficient thing to
do leave us with this a Jim Harbaugh
story from his playing days you go great
Wow Jim Harbaugh I walked into the
huddle I want to say 1991 after being on
and off the practice squad for two years
opening game of the season against the
Minnesota Vikings I was dressed but only
because we only had four guys active
that day and in fact if you had told me
the day or the week before that I was
going to dress for the game and I said
coach I'm going to play he said no
you're going to be dressed but you won't
see time
somebody got hurt so on 3rd and 8th I
think it was I jog out to the huddle and
in Harville opinion and basically so
what are you doing here and I said well
I'm Anthony Morgan's out I'm here so
certain aids ball snapped I've run eight
or twelve yards down the field turn
around and Jim's at maybe 2807 and we
turned a third down into a first down
and we were friends for evermore I hear
that what if you enter Ottaway Dan yeah
and that was the last time Jim Harbaugh
ever hit me between the number I'm not
afraid to say that I mean there was some
they were over my head there was some
that below that one was perfect how
intense was he the greatest competitor
I've ever seen whether we were playing
golf or we were bowling or playing cards
he would just as soon as fighters talk
to you and but you know what when you
get in the huddle that's the guy you
want under Center I mean I saw him get
the crap kicked out of him and just keep
coming back for more so had the ultimate
respect for him knew if he decided to be
a coach that he'd be great the dad was a
great coach obviously his brother's been
a great coach and I call him a friend
he's a little different than he was as a
player but still the the drive to win is
is always there but it Cutler had a
little of Harbaugh in him let's say 15
percent horrible attitude what would
that have changed how we viewed him the
perception I think so I think the
perception in the reality are strikingly
different and I know perception that
ultimately does lead to reality
sometimes I think the perception of Jay
and I've gotten to know Jay pretty well
over the course of his eight plus years
in Chicago I think the Jay Cutler that
came to Chicago is as a 25 year old kid
after three years in Denver was
significantly different than the guy we
saw in Chicago in the last three years
he got married he had three kids he was
more mature he took care of himself more
I think he was a better teammate guys
like him more than they did initially he
cares he's excited
about being in Miami the perception is
is that he doesn't care whether they win
or lose
he works hard he's prepared he cares I
just don't think he'll ever be able to
overcome what the perceptions have been
about him over the course of the last
eight to ten years he's Tom Waddell
former Chicago Bear current co-host of
Waddell and so they tell Selby we settle
oh and great talk to you again Tom great
to talk to you dad's like so much thank
Tom on also an analyst for the
mothership the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience